Stucky it's got a bit lower here
somewhere I think that what do you want
from me mice hey there we go alright
guys okay
you speak Japanese huh I speak Japanese
I invented the language all right [ __ ]
come here babe what are you at then
that's where you're wrong [ __ ]
huh
Oh dick hey hey that means we can go
here maybe yay I made fast first thing
Ealing meaning we'll land without
cheating of course I don't I know karate
[Music]
[Applause]
man oh yeah whatever
are you sure here ah yes
this is adorable look at this town is a
loading noise because servant in with
our amour this time
oh hello what's this I see something
underneath that bookshelf could it be
about happening no no Oh Lowell is this
sure oh no I thought we were friends
I was no sorry penny I'm sorry it wasn't
my developer he was right no I don't
want to scare pity I don't want to do it
oh shut up thought we were friends
I thought you were wrong I mean Jesus
hello father
you still laugh you're still fighting
for your life I feel happy for you ha
job oh holy [ __ ] I didn't need to do it
nice I didn't mean to do it
I got that later Bonnie I'm sorry no no
it was an accident
I said you tell no one there's nothing
going on here nothing spooky oh oh no oh
I don't appreciate cats
Oh oh man Oh KitKat
everyone apparently gets super scared
when Isis shot bow I'm sorry but my hey
third four barrels would never
[Music]
that's for sure alright jump all right
we get stupid crazy [ __ ] honey Oh yep
she's gone she's gone we're safe buddy
ha plans happening it's time we go home
and see your mom or whatever yep see ya
- rose my name is ha hope you enjoyed
this video if you did why not give it a
thumbs up and add it to your favorites
you would do me a great favor of doing
both of these things also leave a
comment saying whatever you want but
most importantly subscribe to come on
bro today so you don't miss out and more
of these moments that I make trust me
you want to regret it
thank you both so much for 100,000
subscribers it's a big number and I'm
proud of every one of you also click
here if you want to see more of these
type of videos I made them into a little
playlist for you and that's pretty much
it
here comes the brofist
[Music]